hey y'all welcome to is this okay where
we talk about things that people are
talking about
I'm niala I'm Chris I'm Morgan that same
Colin Kaepernick's recent protests or
every NFL game due to you know racial
injustice everything that's happening in
the world where blacks are being killed
by police and it's gaining nationwide
attention other people have been doing
it other NFL stars I think there are few
soccer players
and now it's kind of branching out
towards those high schools and you know
so it's getting a lot of attention we
live in a country where there's freedom
of expression and I I don't even think
this is a debate to be had like you
don't believe in what your government is
doing protest why are why are people up
in arms about it do we know why people
are so up in arms a lot of it comes out
of like disrespect for I'm American
America we have the military 911 and
stuff like that but at the same time
when you think about the conversation on
protest it's like well you know they
they always riot and they steal and they
loot and they do whatever so it's like
now I think what's frustrating about
this is that you have an example of
peacefully protesting like all he's
doing is kneeling or sitting and yet you
know people want to furnish Jersey they
want to send him death directly I don't
think he deserves death threats and I
don't think he deserves to be attacked
but I also do think that the people not
all people but some people who are upset
by actions can't be completely
disregarded because I found myself very
torn because I realized in that moment I
was like Harley wants to be like I was
preaching about you should be able to
like protest peacefully as long as it's
peaceful above the blood but if we did
this it was like it also is a huge
symbol and so I can't completely
disregard people who find it offensive
so I was more like in the middle yeah I
do feel like it's a matter of people
that just people disagreeing with him I
don't think they bother looking at like
the nuance and like the actual reasons
behind why he's doing what he's doing I
was in New York City in lower Manhattan
on 9/11 and there are people a lot
closer than me but I was pretty damn in
it for 9/11 and it was a [ __ ]
horrible day and I absolutely like I'm
grateful to the military and family
members that are in the military they
fight for our country that's amazing
they're selfless I think that being
proud of our country and feeling the
patriotism of like you know unity as a
country is not mutually exclusive from
saying there's something wrong here and
we need to do something about it and
someone like Colin Kaepernick is in a
position to like take a knee and start a
national conversation he he took a stand
and did tell anybody because he didn't
want to be stopped and I think that's
important especially as a black American
when we fight for our rights we should
never have to ask permission to
corporate organizations who are majority
white men saying like hey it's okay like
I'm fighting for my
as a black American because something is
wrong and I have that right as an
American to do so but I think it's also
it's like important to note that when he
decided instead of sitting he was gonna
take a knee it was because he went and
had a conversation with a military elder
exactly he said that that that he agreed
like there's a problem in this country
wooden to fix but here's something that
we can do that's in between or when you
think about it all it was was this guy
who was against something that's
obviously a problem and all he was doing
was just not standing or putting his
hamburgers hard for the national anthem
but the fact that it went from like he's
an [ __ ] to I'm gonna die and write
like good for him to like he is like God
I think just like shows how much the
country's like upset right now yeah
everyone use that as this like symbolic
yeah I'm like yeah it's interesting to
see how racism how patriotism is being
it's kind of like the cover for rusev oh
my god oh my god yeah
totally valid point is that in this
birth of a whole other conversation but
the national anthem is racist but I mean
you can like easily look it up
yeah like national anthem is a racist
porn doll and they will be like yeah
no we don't think that part of with all
that said though because the country's
never going to be perfect and if you
just never really allowed to be
patriotic like I actually know the
answer I'm actually asking them just
what you want to be there and I think I
always think back to like early American
history and you think about how this
country was built on the fact that link
you know people threw tea in the water
and they said at this like you know I'm
not gonna do this and so it's like when
I think about that and how that's how
our country started and then I think
about Kaepernick taking a knee it's like
are you serious yeah I almost now feel
like it feels weird than to ever stand
for the national anthem unless the
country's like perfect cuz I feel like
every time you then if you ever do stamp
where are you ignoring right or you yeah
cuz it's not it's not you know modality
it's you know rapists like I don't know
it's just tons of things it's economic
in like justice it's you know there's
all this other stuff and so like at what
point should we just is that should we
never be doing that and does that open
up all these disgraceful I mean I think
like as a society we have like an
internal national gauge that we that
seems to go you know how systemic is
this problem I think another big problem
to those that like we don't like to
revisit things we don't really like to
change things so it's like you know you
want to say why don't you follow the law
I'm like if you just follow a law like
you wouldn't get shot but it's like who
are the law been invited with me in mind
this law didn't see me as a person to
begin yeah never really had me in it's
like scepter looks like that's kind of a
problem and it's like I agree that like
we need some kind of order like that's
the kind of house design
but at the same time like why can't we
revisit these things like when you have
conversations alright so I think that is
the end of today's episode let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below and we'll see you guys next week